three
no no oh my gosh what's up with you two
today huh
so are we live or no do we have your
permission to go live we finally do
gentlemen how are you how are you doing
we are here
yes back zenner is back and we are with
this is what podcast episode number 47
i i think it's fair to say a lot's
happened in the last
week since the last one we did we
haven't been on in one week
it's it's been about a week and and you
know uh
uh i i hope biden made it up the stairs
by now
i think you just said can you put an
escalator on air force one here's a
crazy thing
the first time you saw that what was
your reaction first time you saw that
did you believe it the first time you
saw that we saw it together i thought it
was fa i thought it was a joke
you thought it was fake i was like i was
cracking up
yeah and i was like holy [ __ ] to be
honest i think the one kai
showed me was a little doctored already
yeah not the one that trump was uh you
know
the government spending line drives it
you know that was fake i hope you didn't
do that oh i thought trump
was actually the person that did it
conspiracy theorist that was
a pretty weak editing too wasn't that
kind of a lame
yeah yeah little the ball kind of came
in but what you think about when he said
you think
you know everybody around the world was
sharing that snoop was sharing it you
know people in the nba were sharing it
was just hilarious but what are your
thoughts my thoughts are a gentleman
that old and he didn't break a hip
i mean come on what you're giving him
the slightest little bump and you're and
you're going down for the count
you know everybody stumbles on air force
one i will give him that a lot of
presidents have
had some issues on it so it doesn't
surprise me it's the first of many
i think he might have to start driving i
don't think he can fly in that thing
because the danger
because of the steps unless you could
put an elevator for him i mean go up
i mean seriously those are not easy
steps to navigate and he's not getting
younger
so it they they need to be careful do
you need an escort we're going to see
more footage of that happening though do
you think we're going to see a footage
of
do you think that's going to happen
again or do you think that's the last
time to him for him do you think he's
going to trip again yes i do because
it's happened to
every president almost at some point i
think he's going for the record though i
think he wants to be the all time
well i mean he's had such a good run
over the last uh 60
90 days he said listen i'm promising a
hundred million shots in uh
an american's arms in in the first
hundred days
you know they did it in 58 he took down
somehow donald trump he passed a big
stimulus bill he's on fire the only
thing that can break this man down
is there i think he's gonna have a press
conference and tell us what he's gonna
do right yeah
all right but his biggest fear you gotta
appreciate the number one moment in that
whole thing it wasn't so the stairs was
ridiculous like
rather you're left right up down like
that was absurd hilarious
but he got up you know dusted himself
off and still did the salute
yeah that was the kind was that a comedy
act i mean how did you process all that
when i saw that first i didn't believe
it i'm like oh they're playing another
you know some editor out there is
getting creative and i'm like no he did
fall three times yeah yeah yeah
and then next you know everybody send me
a message did you see it did you see it
i'm like yeah i saw it already yeah i
thought it was uh pretty funny it's
always
funny when a successful whoever powerful
person has a
moment like that i think it's it's the
world likes it but what's the number one
embarrassing moment that comes to mind
that you can think of
number one of anybody yeah just like a
president a president a big
big-time public figure i'm assuming
you're going to give us a trump story
i'm not a trump story no no no no
what's yours i'm asking you i don't have
a [ __ ]
i i have the most hilarious one let's
hear it this was
um george the original george h.w
bush when he was meeting with the
japanese uh
that's right he threw up constituents
and in the middle of
like lunch he's just like oh god no he
did
pukes on it guys pull it up that was in
george
no you can't show it if it's on the news
you can't what about just a picture
the point is the guy barfed on that's
crazy
like me throwing up on tom center right
now which i've attempted to do multiple
times somehow but
what well let's how about we do some
good news instead of what you just did
right now we're going to throw up i
don't know where that came from but that
was the most embarrassing moment we went
from biting tripping to
president bush throwing up and i
remember that
a japanese delegate
now that you're talking about it i think
the funnier one was when the guy threw
his shoe at president bush the son
that was good that was awesome and he he
was pretty cool i was pretty you could
tell he used to box back in the days
okay all right so good news here's some
good news krispy kremes just announced
okay if you adam specifically you if you
show your vaccination card oh yeah
krispy kremes
is willing to give free donuts for the
rest of the year anybody that goes to
krispy kremes
and shows their vaccination card you're
gonna be given
free donuts for the rest of the year
okay what do you think about that
i think there's definitely someone
that's like i was on the fence about
this whole vaccine but
you're gonna throw in some krispy kreme
i'm in like there's who's that first
thing that converts anybody
do you think all cops in america are
like i'm getting my vaccination card
i want to know who the first person like
there's someone on the fence
but they're gonna hear that news and
they're going to be like i got it
there is no doubt this is going to
convert some people a free donut
hell yeah take a look you'll be
sarcastic no i'm not i'm being 100
i need i need a serious alert for me
because you can't tell sometime but i
need a button i am being serious because
your point
have you seen america it is unbelievable
how out of shape this country is you get
reminded of it every now and then go to
costco
walk around you'll see how out of shape
this country is so i do believe that the
the krispy kreme incentive will work for
them it's a brilliant move because you
go in there how can you just get one
you leave with a dozen and the final
thing is i could never afford to do it
because gas is so damn expensive in
california
if i drive five miles i'm broke i mean i
cannot believe the gas prices yeah it's
the gas what is it right now
it's over four bucks okay what is it
here in florida
under three okay yeah but it use it used
to be five bucks
uh 10 15 years ago when the whole oil
thing was going on so four bucks is bad
california but
they just added a gas tax last year so
you know
yeah here's what i think i think the
fake id business
used to be very good back in the days i
think the fake vaccination card business
is coming back i think you're going to
see some guys saying
hey i'll get you a fake vaccination card
for 50 bucks go to krispy kremes to get
uh
free donuts well there's already fake um
covid test results that are out there
indeed get out of here oh yeah get out
of here i know a guy
i know a guy adams serves the black his
name might be
sam but internet yeah yeah i don't have
to search too far i go
right over to my uh colombian friend
over there he looks proud get out of
here
sam are they really selling fake covered
results so so people that are working
and they want to take a break they just
go get a fake
positive test
you thought people wanted to show a
negative result so they can get back
with their lives these are people
showing
fake positives so they can take them for
example somebody's been fake positive
for four weeks
maybe it's sponsored by uh dr john doe
at down the street we're looking
for a diagnosis i had in june
hey i think that answers your question
if people will go get a vaccine for a
donut if they're getting fake vaccines
so they don't have to work they'll go
get the donuts wow
yeah wow i think they should implement a
rule where like
if you run a mile you can get
uh you know something free like we're
rewarding
fatness and sloppiness and slaw three
donuts why are you upset by that that's
that's your side what what why are you
offended by that look
you know maybe i ate a little too many
carbs this weekend and i'm feeling
guilty and i'm projecting right now i'm
just trying to be healthy during the day
so tell us about how would so this
saturday you partied on miami they shut
down miami the curfew
what happened this week what a [ __ ] show
i mean
we're going to get into this topic right
now so yeah that's what happened
okay i'll just give it to you from my
personal experience and then we can kind
of
go go deeper i remember being at this
place called the soho house which is
sort of a local i mean they're they're
in every sort of major city new york la
chicago the private club for me
it's a private club yeah it got to be
four five thousand all of your
membership
yeah a little bit cheaper but in certain
certain places but point
is uh we were there hanging out like you
know it's just a weekend chill out
locals
and people start passing around like
alert did you see this alert to see this
it's probably four o'clock in the
afternoon at this point is by the time
we're getting alerts on our phones text
messages so you start clubbing at four
o'clock
no we're just very impressed about where
the beach is just wrapping up
this is not this is not a party scene
you're hanging out by the pool you're
having a beach you're having lunch it's
nothing crazy
um and there's alerts going on they're
saying that the entertainment district
south like the heart of south beach is
shutting down at 8 00 pm
shutting down so we're all like i mean
we have dinner plans it's the weekend
now which mayor shut it down because
there's too many there's a couple mayors
there's a specifically the mayor of
miami beach's name his name is dan
gelber okay um not mayor suarez he's the
mayor of the city of miami and then
there's the
uh a different mayor uh mayor of the
entire miami-dade
county so this was specifically miami
beach
and in my opinion this was
certainly a necessary move like
look you're in california you know that
you've been on lockdown
for a full-on year and everyone hates
gavin newsom because
i mean they're recalling newsome because
he's too way too far left
way too locked down you know
precautionary measures
you know people have been praising
florida and our and our friend friend of
the show ron desantis for
you know keeping florida open and
keeping jobs and and bringing business
but this is sort of the ugly side of
staying open so it's the perfect recipe
when you have you know an open state
cheap flights
spring break stimulus uh pent-up demand
everyone's coming to south beach and in
this certain pocket of
of neighborhood it's the party scene so
in my opinion what they should have done
differently was not announce it at
three four o'clock on a saturday oh by
the way bedtimes in four hours everybody
are you freaking kidding me they're
already out there on the streets having
a great time partying
say starting tomorrow sunday this is
what we're going to be implementing late
already
yeah but it's they they rolled it out
horribly
and i mean people are look people have
been on lockdown for a frickin year
you're telling me you're getting a 50
flight to miami beach and usually the
hotels are 400 bucks a night and you're
paying
150 and you're coming down with your
buddies and you just got another 1400
in your stimulus because these aren't
spring breakers these aren't like
20 year old college kids it could be 30
year old grown men or just yo i'm trying
to get out get it in women man
and look you know
masks social distancing that's not even
a freaking thing going on right now you
know it's hot out so are you wearing a
mask
were you being socially responsible at
the club of course
then i'm actually being said no i you
know were you wearing like a nice
look at him i'm just am i trying to hang
out with ten thousand people like
at a freaking concert no but it might
social like look at us right now am i
wearing a mask no but it's not
to me like you know you're you know it's
a messed up situation when
were you wearing a mask is like the
tenth thing to bring up
right like we weren't a mass it's like
there's so many other things going on
here
so and then there's the ugly ugly ugly
side of all this where people are
getting arrested half of
i think there's a thousand arrests over
the last few weeks half of them are out
of state
people from out of state thousand
arrests in the last few weeks in miami
yes
okay and half over 50 percent are from
out of state so these aren't locals
getting loose
crazy people like tom coming in from
california trying to live it up
yeah can i have a shot at this go for it
go for it this this
what a coincidence it's a red state
right where all these arrests are
happening
it goes from red to blue quite
consistent we'll call it i'm going to
look at this a little bit differently
from a different perspective maybe
somebody in the media or somebody that's
a little bit more skeptical of things
this thing seems staged to me this isn't
just a coincidence where
3 000 people can't handle their alcohol
suddenly on saturday night so they got
to start jumping on cars and
no this is planned i mean i think the
chaos
when you see chaos like this in this
country now
there is some level of organization to
it i'm not saying
what you mean organization it's not a
coin they keep branding it as spring
breakers going wild like you said these
are not spring breakers they can't
afford to go to south beach
there's no college student on in the
country that says hey man
i'm going to spring break on south beach
they just don't do it they go to
fort lauderdale they go to destin they
go to fort myers they go where it's
cheap
right where the booze is cheap the
hotels are cheap and where there's other
college kids
these are adults this is this seems to
me
that it's a little bit more organized
and and and not a coincidence that
people are just
happy to go bonkers because the
country's finally opened it's been open
in florida a long time they were
partying on
new year's eve and new year's here in in
florida so i don't think it's
i don't think it's that i really go deep
tom go deep go deep here
meaning like who's organizing this i'm
gonna i'm gonna stay with the fact that
i think it's more organized
than a random thing that just happens to
break out politically
organized are you saying like social
action let's let's face it here
here let's face it so so let's just say
give some credence to tom's point right
for the sake of debate
and conversation that will happen i want
to have that okay who would do that
just think about why would they do that
and who would do that who
ended up getting a ton of praise during
covet at the end
not at the beginning at the beginning
who was god of the christians
cuomo was unbelievably more responsible
than anybody else and knew some
how's cuomo looking today cuomo and
deshawn watson are in the same place
right what the hell is that story about
this yeah that's a very weird story
what's going on there anyways he keeps
actually cuomo's in a different place
than deshawn watson but
similarities they're just going after
espn wrote an article about deshaun
watson
espn typically protects players right
because they tell him
they hit him yesterday and it wasn't i
don't know if you read that or not it's
like 12 different stories no
it's unbelievable so but when you look
at cuomo then he gets there and then all
of a sudden the santis is everywhere
and abbott didn't get the credit at the
cpac to be someone that could run for
office
whether he does or not that's on him but
the leading candidate right now is um
desantis so you have to if you think the
same way twitter silenced trump
and everybody silas and trump and
youtube is saying we would consider in
the future bringing trump back and
lifting the suspension google's thinking
about lifting the suspension twitter
said there's no way in the world
and now trump is talking about the fact
that he may start his own social media
company that's been in the talks we'll
talk about that here in a minute
desantis is a leading candidate you got
two people that are leading candidates
for 2024
one is pence one is desantis and trump
is the wild card because
no one knows what he's going to be doing
nobody knows what he's going to be doing
so if there is some credence to that you
have to kind of give a black eye to the
state of florida
and this is one way of doing it now it
wasn't as big as people thought it was
going to be
if that was the case i think it was a
better strategy of doing that
but to go back and say you're shutting
down at four o'clock it's kind of weird
it's kind of like
it's it's as if like you know criminal
activity is happening shut it down panic
it was too much of an abrupt reaction by
the
miami uh uh beach mayor that's different
than
uh is it suarez francis wars is the city
of miami he's the city of miami
this is my developer did you bail did
you leave or did you stick around and
see something no i
look i was at i took a mask on he stayed
there
he took a boat to a different part of
town shout out to my
good buddy marco and chris parcello
those guys have a gorgeous place called
joya it's across from
fisher gorgeous place very local scene
or new york tourist definitely not
spring break
and people got the pr the biggest
problem was
they shut down all the highways so if
you're like i haven't
they shut down you couldn't get to the
freaking beach
so if you live in miami beach or
you're staying at a hotel and you're
like yeah i was just downtown miami in
wynwood and i
had dinner i saw a family good luck
getting back what are you talking about
it was so
freaking poorly planned and then you add
on top of that like they're shutting
down streets
and then then all the cops are being
moved to the entertainment district
basically between
5th and 16th lincoln road it's all three
blocks ocean drive collins and
washington
if you're familiar with south beach and
there's just partying going on
like crazy so all the cops are going
over there shootings
shootings yeah people shooting bullets
up in the air it was stupid
yeah so i i do here's what i'll say the
the positive i do actually applaud
your mentality thinking what was it
planned
what's going on in my opinion this was
just
fluke idiots just no you're telling
drunk
absolutely not you're telling drunk
people look at the footage four o'clock
not drunk people drunk people yeah
what do you mean i'm telling you they're
out there partying like people can act
like that this is not the that is not
the action of drunk people people get
drunk in every city people get drunk in
maui
they don't do that all right okay i'm
yeah when's the last time you went out
and partied and drank in south beach
it's it's very special i have done it uh
frankly when's the last time but i don't
know i mean
a while ago what's your favorite point
is these people are drinking
their salad
okay this is the first time people have
been out partying in a year
pent up demand but then do you have a
desire to go to jail and get arrested i
haven't been able to party
look the problem was wasn't so much that
they were partying and drinking it's
that
they're like oh yeah now you got to go
back to your hotel they're like what are
you talking about bro i'm here on
vacation
no no no go back to your hotel i think
there's some people that were probably
in that mode no
they're like i'm in the middle of having
a great time and you want me to go to my
hotel at 7 30 buddy not happening
and those people are like [ __ ] that so
case study
you take sam with you a camera i'm going
to tom and take them to south beach
all of you guys get drunk over here okay
so we got we got enough news on mike can
i take you guys a
a a situation with mario and tom last
night tom ellsworth so yesterday
mario and tom come over it's 11 o'clock
we're sitting we're having a
conversation miami's playing the pacers
you know sabonis gets uh his sixth foul
just the fluke of a foul it's overtime
they're supposed to
lose the game miami hits a couple threes
next thing you know
it's over i'm knocked out at this point
like it's like midnight because you know
watching
games in florida i got to tell you it's
not right games go until
midnight so you got to be right if the
lakers are playing at 10 30 that game is
going to one o'clock in the morning it's
really not worth my time to watch it to
one o'clock in the morning
anyways i'm hearing that mario's telling
tom about an investment he made my gosh
about the one thing about mario
the guy can keep a straight face when
he's pull a prank he's got a serious
side
a very serious side yes but he's got a
side that he pulls prank you got to give
him credit so mario says
you know i recently messed into a
company i said i'm like i'm wow mario
invest into a company i'm quietly
listening to it mario and tom's like
really what kind of it says ten thousand
dollars
he says i'm listening to a cbd company
and tom's like wow that's great so tell
me about the company
it's a christian owner it's a christian
noises what's the company called it's
called holy smokes that's it
so they're going serious and i'm sitting
there just
trying to hold myself back because i
know mario's pulling a prank
so tom grabs the phone it's on online
and we're like is tom looking up holy
smokes christian cbd
and this goes on for a while until
eventually mario and i just can't hold
her so i started cracking i almost peed
my pants but i thought it was hilarious
so tom
we all want to know did you actually
google
holy smokes christian cbd company or not
how many of you if you're watching this
biz doc you follow his content
tom ellsworth who actually thinks tom
googled holy smokes
christian company cbd by the way if a
christian person ever wanted to start
a cbd company that's actually a great
name if you think about it fantastic
holy smokes.com you know a wheat for
christians how's that not already or
taken
yeah right sorry about the url maybe
mario's actually doing this and we don't
know anything about it he's raising
money on this side and this was worth
getting uh
attention out there anyways okay so
miami it is what it is we talked about a
bunch of different things we'll be down
there this weekend filming will you
actually be down there this yeah we're
gonna go film
when you go and tell everybody when
you're going so some people may be out
there it's a saturday or sunday night
two to four o'clock
saturday two to four o'clock okay that's
not really saturday night
in the morning or am pm okay
p.m in the afternoon because we want the
light okay so we got a lot of stories
to we got a lot of stores to go through
here why don't we go through the feud
between
elon musk and bernie sanders okay
so seven months ago eight months ago
bernie sanders berated elon musk
just a bunch of things he's making too
much money because i think
uh elon musk had uh gotten what uh
2.4 billion dollars of subsidies for
tesla
and he got 5.6 million dollars of
subsidies for spacex
and they're going back and forth it was
a feud and elon really didn't say much
but
sanders pretty much trashed them right
this last week it got a little bit ugly
where they were going back and forth on
twitter if you want to bring this up
bernie sanders started off by sending
this tweet he said
we are in a moment in american history
where two guys elon musk and jeff bezos
own more wealth
than the bottom 40 percent of people in
this country that level of greed and
inequality
is not only immoral it's unsustainable
okay
that's his first tweet then you have
elon musk that responds saying i am
accumulating resources to help make life
multi-planetary and extend the light of
consciousness to the stars
sanders responds space travel is an
exciting idea
but right now we need to focus on earth
and create a progressive tax system
so that children don't go hungry people
are not homeless and all americans have
health care
the level of inequality in america is
obscene and a threat
to our democracy thoughts well he's a
quack
i mean i look at the words he is who
qualified
bernie yeah progressive tax system okay
three words there
so there's no homelessness we have a
progressive tax system in california
have you seen the homelessness there
there's a progressive
tax system in seattle in the state of
washington homeless is completely out of
control there
you know bernie has a brand that he has
to sell and he's an
anti-capitalist guy so he's got two
people square in his crosshairs
it's musk and it's bezos and it's
perfect for him
um he can rail on them constantly yeah
but here's my problem
is it greed i mean it's not like they're
stealing money it's not like he's an old
oligarch
or ogler or whatever the word is in
russia where you're giving an industry
essentially and then you just steal all
the money
these guys have started a business from
scratch essentially
invested everything they had and done
very very well for themselves i
i'm curious to see if bernie sanders
ever orders anything on amazon
do you think he doesn't just because he
can't allow himself to
to not support and do you think jeff
bezos has gone
and pull up his profile to see what kind
of things bernie
sanders orders on amazon can you imagine
hey mary can you
pull up bernie sanders profile on
vermont and tell us what he orders you
know i guarantee you
he doesn't drop right he doesn't drive a
tesla i know that
do you know what car bernie sanders
drives is it the a i i
which one is it the audi no i think he
used to have one of those now he drives
the subaru forester
is that is that still a thing i can
actually see him in a super i think i
think that is more fitting for him to be
aligned with his message than it is the
yeah out the audi here's my final
thought on this
and this is completely unproductive
what he's doing with this twitter feud
it keeps his brand alive
because he does have a brand all right
this is him okay we all know his
background
here's a better idea why don't you go
spend some time with these guys and mine
their brain a little bit instead of
getting trying to get all their money
i mean they solve every other damn
problem in this country i mean compare
the
government's united states postal
service with amazon
who's a little bit more efficient when
it comes to delivering products okay
maybe there's something to learn from
bezos
or you know looks like we're going to
solve the high-speed internet problem
for the whole world
thanks to elon musk treat these guys
as your allies they're brilliant learn
from them
tap their resources in their mind and
figure out a way to help the entire
country
instead of just trying to make a money
grab constantly adam
yeah you know actually i have some
pretty strong opinions on the on this
topic so
just for a second let's pretend that we
don't know either of their names so
bernie is b and elon's e we don't know
one guy's like look
we got some major freaking issues here
on earth
in america wealth inequality whether
you're on either side of
the aisle is a real thing you know
billionaires are getting wealthier
uh you talking about um united
healthcare
universal healthcare education a living
wage on a minimum minimum minimum wage
infrastructure fossil fuels clean energy
and he's just kind of you know
that's what quote unquote person b is
talking about
and then the other person's like yeah
but mars bro
mars and he's like what dude you're
talking about mars like
let's focus on we got major problems we
got a pandemic going on right here
uh can we just focus on earth for a
second and he's just like listen man
mars so it's funny because i do respect
elon musk
you know i'm not a fan boy or anything
like that but like the guy she's curious
to know where you're going with this go
ahead okay the guy's a beast yeah
the point is it's so easy to be like
bernie is a quack
bernie's a socialist he's an idiot one
thing i know about bernie
one thing i know about bernie yeah
whether you agree with him politically
or disagree with him politically the guy
clearly cares
clearly cares he he empathizes with what
the hell the
is plaguing our country whether you
believe with his tax premise or whether
you believe in
socialism or not the guy cares you think
he cares like the way you think he cares
i think how where are you going with
that like you mean you think it's all an
act
you know how i think he cares here's how
i think he cares do you remember the
movie
uh what was that movie paul tom cruise
catherine zeta-jones tom cruise is a
star
and he's performing and katherine
zeta-jones is that rock of ages
you know the apollo she's like the local
politician
what is the name of that movie who if
you remember this movie comment below
if it's like a rock of ages he's a rock
star
tom cruise is that the movie yeah
you have never you've never seen that
okay let me see what the name of it is
anyways in that movie
in that movie what's the premise of the
story do you remember that
okay the premise of that story it's a uh
is it tom cruise
uh the premise of that movie um i mean i
i have to figure out exactly what it is
is it this one
okay anyways the premise of that movie
is the following so catherine zeta jones
keeps coming and screaming and i cannot
believe you're doing this you know this
person is bad for the community
he's it's not rock of ages something
else he's terrible for the community
you know he's he's turning our kids into
you know rock stars and our kids are now
smoking weed and she keeps doing this
and showing up over and over and over
and over
and over again right and eventually i
said what the hell is wrong with this
woman what do you have against tom
cruise
tom cruise in the movie every time he
performed this would keep come up every
single time this
he performed rock of ages every time he
would perform this would come up
eventually at the end of the movie i'm
ruining it for everybody who hasn't seen
it
he's performing she shows up
he leaves the stage spots are on the
other side of the rail
walks across goes up to her
kisses her and walks off and she just
knews buckle and what happened she fell
in love with them
years ago he didn't end up being with
her he left her broke her heart for her
entire life she flipped against him
and she used to be one of those groupies
that was crazy about him right
i think bernie's cat catherine
zeta-jones i don't
no i think someone in his life
offended him so bad that he's made it a
mission
to get after all these rich people
whether it's a rich uncle
whether it's a rich dad whether it's a
rich friend whether it's an
ex's rich dad that you know he just
didn't like bernie
somebody there offended this guy because
if you look at bernie
can you go to young bernie sanders i
wonder what he looks like what does a
young bernie sanders look like in his
20s
you know uh young bernie sanders click
there go to images
young bernie sanders okay i mean you can
you can tell this guy was a
uh yeah he he was an interesting guy but
just looking at what this guy looks like
he
looks like a young rudy giuliani okay
hi you have to be here to kind of know
what that means
but the moral of the stories i think
someone offended him and he got upset
and he's doing what he's got
he's got you basically think he's got
some deep rooted oh buddy it's so deep
none of us know about the guy got
married in soviet union he went to
soviet union for his
honeymoon i mean somebody got a hold of
this guy very very early
were you going to make another point
with this where the other guys are
saying space and this guy's saying
i mean that's just sort of the
overarching theme here i mean all you
have
look one thing this is actually pretty
interesting
so elon musk as much as he's a
capitalist
you know a lot of his wealth comes from
this corporate welfare from these uh
government subsidies he's got five
billion in subsidies so
you know just using bernie's words he
says what a hypocrite
elon musk has received billions in
corporate welfare from u.s taxpayers
now he wants to stop 30 million
americans who lost jobs from receiving
600 bucks a week in unemployment while
his wealth has gone up 50 billion
dollars so
this was um back in july most more
recently
um every time elon musk pokes fun at
government assistance for the 99
remember he would be worth nothing
without the 5 billion dollars in
corporate welfare
elon musk loves corporate socialism for
himself and then rugged capitalism for
everyone else
so he does have a point there okay
elon musk does get billions and billions
of corporate subsidies
there's a very easy argument for that
there's a very argument for that so many
years ago i asked the following question
i said okay
so say you raise taxes from 30 to 40
take whatever each percent is right now
by the way fy if you're listening to
this let me tell you what what
announcement was just made
that i think everybody needs to know uh
if
you have are having any kind of capital
gains anything going on with major tax
event make sure it happens in 2021
not in 2022 because 2022 get ready to
force
taxes to skyrocket in ways you've never
seen before
my prediction i could be wrong i'm just
telling you 2022 2023
and it's not going to change until 2024
2025 probably 2025
is when the taxes are going to go back
to normal 2022
taxes are going to the roof let me give
you a couple hints on why
this could potentially happen so number
one
uh there's an article that came out this
morning with
morning brew okay and they talk about
how the wealthiest one percent of u.s
households failed to disclose 21
of their income according to a new study
done by who
irs researchers make sense on who would
do
that research the top one percent is
failing to disclose 21
their income okay so what do they do
some of these incomes are automatically
reported to irs but other income stream
can slip by the agency's auditors
who sophisticated strategies including
with sophisticated inc
strategies including what which helped
the top one percent of it offshore
accounts
pass-through businesses llc they want to
target
llc's llcs for years have been what
through businesses which means what
it's a partnership popular with family
firms investment funds real estate
businesses
they're perfectly legal but since their
income isn't taxed at the corporate rate
it's easier to hide and some pilot some
politicians want to raise taxes on
llc catastrophic because that's small
businesses that are doing what they're
doing these are not billionaires it's a
small llc that we're talking about right
but watch what it ends up with
enforcement isn't
also what it used to be okay audit rates
have slipped over the last decade
as the irs lost fifteen thousand
staffers
the agency commissioner charles redick
brace for impact
asked congress for more funds arguing
for every one dollar spent
on enforcement the returns are five to
seven
dollars so it means we're gonna go
auditing
more people collecting unpaid income
taxes from the one percent could bring
175 billion dollars
into the treasury annually that's the
study
now when you read this what do you say
there's two ways you can read this
article one is what
uh okay yeah let's go find this money
from these rich people and the other one
is what
if there's any job you don't want to
increase it's what
auditors that's what you don't want but
we've been i mean i've been audited
every single year i'm at a different
place i'm constantly going through not
fun i spend a few hundred thousand
dollars i have to do that because of
what i go through totally get it
where we are i'm not disputing it i
totally understand what they
there's a there's a need for their job
but if they're going in this direction
and the sale is what for every dollar
you spent we make what
five to seven dollars now if the other
side
if the congress the the is being sold
this concept by the agency commissioner
charles reddick
which is controlled by who right now the
left buys buys into this and says yeah
that makes sense
they get a bunch of auditors what are
they preparing for they're going to
raise taxes next year it's going to be
announced this year and how it's going
to be
it'll be into effect 1-1 2022
the people that are the people that
backed up this administration
are telling them whatever you're going
to do don't do it this year let me make
my sales this year
so i can be okay but then start it next
year if you need to because if they
don't
then in the midterms they're going to
get destroyed because they didn't keep
their commitment of raising taxes
because that was one of the things biden
campaign and when biden was going out he
was saying what we're going to raise
taxes
we're raising taxes we're raising taxes
and they said four hundred thousand
dollars now
it's family households above four
hundred thousand dollars which means
it's really what two hundred thousand
dollars
if you're making two hundred thousand
dollars or higher you're most likely
going to increase your taxes corporate
taxes going up we talked about this last
week
this is the point i'm going to make it
make you with uh elon musk and bernie
sanders
ten years ago nine years ago i did a
video um
uh i did something having to do with
taxes but this is the question that i
asked say you got a billion dollars okay
a billion dollars you have to choose
between two people getting this billion
dollars and the goal is to turn this
billion dollars into 10 billion dollars
that's the goal you're investing a
billion dollars to turn it into 10
billion dollars and create more jobs
who do you trust more to take that
billion dollars
to turn it into 10 billion versus a
billion dollars that's going to be
wasted and nothing happens to them
do you trust putting it into the hands
of an entrepreneur or an innovator like
an elon musk
or do you trust putting it in the hands
of a government guy who do you trust
if those are the two options i'm going
with elon what other options do we have
giving it to the people ubi or something
oh well
okay then let's ask that question if you
give it to the people so you got three
options now
you give it to an innovator you give it
to the people you give it to the
government
who duplicates that money the most and
creates the most commerce
commerce who creates the most commerce
creates the most common commerce
jobs economy oh jobs are commerce it's
the same thing the more
business there is the more employees you
need elon musk will do the best with
jobs perfect commerce if you're giving
people thousands of dollars they'll go
spend it and do what's best for their
family oh actually that's not how it
works the more money you give to the
people
the more you get their level of
intensity to lower to rely on what
to rely on the government so if you give
it directly to the people
the people are going to keep coming back
to the government it's like starting
allowance too early with high money
you're now expected to be given higher
allowances that's just the expectation
they're going to keep coming back to you
so we know the highest return is going
to be where
in an elon musk top of a person small
and i'm not saying specifically
llamas who am i talking about small
business owners put the money into the
guy that's creating a job and saying
government i don't need you i don't need
you to pay me for anything
let me go create a job you put the money
into the government the government's
going to say what we need more irs
agents we need more this let me create a
new department give this money to this
let me do this research
and all of those researches goes away
wasted and a billion dollars of tax
money went
nowhere and then you give to the people
you're just telling them
in about six months from now you're
going to come back asking for more in
about six months from then you're going
to come back asking for more
i am turning you into a victim if i keep
giving you free money
if i keep giving you free money that's
what happens so going back to the
argument between these two guys
this is a philosophical debate i want to
tell you about a conversation i had
yesterday with dan price but i want to
first go to
tom because i think tom's got something
to share you know why
can't we just say bernie sanders you are
wrong
i mean people are afraid to say it he's
wrong i mean you keep jacking up taxes
like this
and that's your only agenda is to just
try to squeeze the wealthy a little bit
more
san francisco is an unlivable city right
now
unlivable i mean if you were to go and i
have if you were to be in the city of
san francisco and see for your own eyes
what it's like
you would not believe it a few weeks ago
i had a drive
through downtown l.a to get to the
children's hospital dash was getting his
uh his boot off his foot after breaking
his leg
and literally driving through downtown
you could
smell downtown l.a you could smell it
through closed windows
of your car it's really really bad in
some of these cities that believe
that taxing your way to solve every
problem is the solution
and i just wish we could maybe it'd be
okay to say
hey bernie sanders you are wrong you
know or maybe just an objective person
to say
no you're incorrect same thing with dr
fauci i mean it's these guys that have
been in these positions for so long they
can get away with saying whatever they
want
and we're supposed to take it for gospel
because one's a doctor one's a senator
but you know in 185 billion that you're
talking about the irs would get in
newfoundland
where would that go i mean how long did
that even last that's more auditors
right more government employees right
but i mean if and they said they'd find
185 billion dollars how long would that
even last in the treasury yeah the other
tax bill that you have to watch is that
one that elizabeth warren and bernie
want for the uber wealthy yeah where
they think they can generate about three
trillion over the next 10 years
but they're coming after that money they
see it out there and they're oh it's
going to happen next year
listen it's going to happen next year
they by the way the reason why it's
going to happen next year they have to
do it pre
midterms they have to do pre-midterms
fyi
if i'm a democrat and i'm a democrat
that i have biden and kamala on my team
and i have to worry about keeping aoc
sanders happy
and elizabeth warren if you don't do the
tax plan next year
when can you do the tax plan let me say
this one more time if they don't drive
their tax plan next year
what happens when's the next time
they're going to get an opportunity like
that the year after the midterm there's
no way they'll have that because they're
going to lose the house and they're
going to lose the senate right now it's
50 50.
all it takes is a couple and the house
is making some momentum
people typically get upset at midterms
and it flips it goes from all
you know typically you'll see a
republican have control of all three you
only have two years to impose your
philosophies
two years later you lose one of them
house or senate then you can't go as
aggressive
they're gonna impose this in the next 12
months it'll most likely happen in 2022
when it happens midterms they're going
to say we told you we were going to do
this
we did then they'll all be united joe
kamala elizabeth warren sanders aoc all
of those guys from different camps
they'll be united going into 2024
because they want to continue this for
four more years
so that's what i see happening here and
that's one the reason so so remember
this here's a couple targets uh
florida major target for the state of
florida is gonna be targeted hardcore
okay hardcore it's gonna be targeted
desantis
public enemy number one right now number
two uh texas
is gonna get destroyed they're gonna be
hitting texas non-stop okay and by the
way texas is not as right-wing as people
think it is
texas is going more to the center and it
can be flipped just so everybody knows
they got people like beto over there
they got a lot of
superstars over there florida that's
coming up you know what's the next state
they're gonna
they're gonna target you're gonna see
tennessee being there you're gonna see
nevada being there
any of the states that are no state
taxes are number one enemy right now
because it's working
because it's working people are moving
there it's enemy the state
number one so you're gonna see a lot of
articles talking about terrible
lifestyle terrible living not the
funnest not this all these statistics
and research done by the government that
they get to control whatever kind of
data
that they want to control to sell their
points
the challenge with this is the following
yesterday i talked to dan price
i don't know if you remember dan price
can you pull up dan price uh uh if you
if you see who dan price is if anyone's
gonna remember this guy
i think it's to be you uh uh pull up the
article don't go
images i know this guy paid everybody
the same salary yeah paid everybody the
same salary so i got to tell you how
this thing went yesterday
okay just how this thing went yesterday
fyi
if you guys didn't know this when this
guy did his
news talking about that he's lowering
his income from 1.1 million to 70
000 and he's going to pay every single
one of his employees
70 000 you ready what happened to that
story
500 million interactions on social media
and nbc's video becoming the most shared
in network
history besides from that it was the
most read article on new york times for
the week
front page of reddit two days in a row
front page of msnbc
front page of nbc front page of abc news
mashable
trending article on upworthy buzzfeed
trending on twitter for two days trended
on facebook for three days that story
what year was it 2015 when that came out
okay this is obama era
obama years prior to that gave him a
recognition as the entrepreneur of the
year
uh uh himself it was the sba
entrepreneur of the year award
presented to him by barack obama okay so
now watch what happened yesterday it's
very important to to hear the story
because
first of all i will plotted him to
coming on i told everybody i'm i'm not
sure why this guy said yes
because i was surprised that he said yes
so i told him i said first of all
kudos to you for saying yes to this and
i said i appreciate you for doing this
because it's a case study for the rest
of us
rush limbaugh bashed this guy trashed
him he said he's going to go out of
business it's the ultimate socialistic
story
etc etc well fast forward to today
his business is doing 45 million dollars
a year and they net
four to five million dollars per year so
he's got a ten percent ebitda
what he's got four and a half million
dollar profits is a solid profits that
he's got
so we're talking yesterday and i said so
tell me how you're doing this he says
well you know i had an employee that was
making thirty five thousand dollars i
went outside i see him smoking
cigarettes he's
stressed out he calls me and he says all
you care about is money and tell a look
at all this we're not making any money
and that hurt me for three days i
thought about it i came back i said
guess what i'm paying everybody seventy
thousand dollars
his executives were furious they left
that he had and he didn't
have to take a pay cut the executive of
course they did everybody
took a pay cut his brother ended up
suing him i think in 2015 we didn't talk
about it yesterday
and you know this guy was a genius
christian
guy who memorized the bible in fifth and
sixth grade he would go to
con contest grew up in a very
conservative family right
so as we're going through the
conversation with them i asked him a
question i said let me ask you
so you ended up giving your seventy
thousand dollars income to everybody
including yourself he said yes
he hated peter thiel he called peter
thiel out nonstop
he was not a fan of elon musk a fan of
aoc a fan he called aoc the future he
was a fan of sanders a fan of sanders
and he was a fan of
not a fan of uh bezos i said what do you
think about biden give me one word that
you think about biden he said please
he says please like please i said what's
the one word you think
about trump he said who so that's kind
of where his position's at right
i said let me ask you a question he says
what's that i said since
you're doing four and a half million
dollar your inc four and a half million
dollars a net
i said you know if you wanted to sell
your company
in merchant account services you get 20
20 to 40 x
which means you're a hundred million
dollar guy he says he goes like this at
first right i said
what percentage of the company do you
own he says i own 100
i said i think that's unfair i said i
think you should i said how many
employees you get he said 200 i said i
think you should follow through
and give 200 of your employees each a
half a percent
because you're right now worth 100
million dollars then you backtracked
well it wouldn't work why wouldn't it
work well because of this this
because if we were to do it you know i
would never sell the company to anybody
because of somebody that bought the
company they wouldn't have to agree to
pay everybody 70 000
i've never laid off anybody i've never
fired anybody and that just wouldn't
work because we're not 100 million
dollar company so no you're on a million
dollar company
you got four and a half million dollars
of profits what do you guys do with the
profits well we talked about it
and then it led to the conversation
being
i said so let me get this straight you
call all these guys scam artists because
he says capitalism as a scam he says you
also bought into it he's telling me like
you also bought into this camp
it's a fascinating interview when this
thing comes out
i said so why wouldn't you give equity
to everybody he says there is no value
in the equity but you want 100
of it if it's 70 000 give it to
everybody i said what's wrong with the
way the system is in america the
capitalists can make money i don't mind
you being worth 100 million dollars
that's why i want you to follow through
he says well think about it it's a good
idea i'll think about it i said no
it's not fair you're worth 100 million
why not take that 100 million and share
it with everybody else everybody's worth
at least a half a million dollars
do that right so and then he started
talking all these rich people he called
that bezos he called that musk he called
out all these guys
and he wishing to raise taxes what do we
need to raise taxes to he says i'm okay
if we go to 90 percent i said you want
to
he says we need to raise taxes on rich
people up to 90 i said what country has
it worked
in america we did it before and it
worked that's true
i mean not that it worked no true it's
true that it happened but it was
hollywood million dollar earners et
cetera et cetera in the
30s that's when communism was on the
uprise and they thought communism was
the way to go so far
yes exactly so that was kind of hey
let's increase the taxes didn't work
it's not worked in any other country but
he's saying this i said can i ask you a
question
how much money you gave to charity last
year i'm not going to answer that
question for i said i'm just curious
because you sound so charitable how much
money did you give to charity last year
what's the point here bernie sanders is
telling others how to live
and go look at how much money he gives
away you tell me who's made a bigger
positive impact for the world between
the two
it's not even one is creating the other
is
regulating let me get this straight one
is creating
opportunities getting us to think and
find ways to improve
the other one is sitting out there
saying we gotta tax this guy more and
slow him down
so if you and i had a choice of having
10 bernie sanders
and 10 elon musks in the world which one
makes the world a better place 10 elon
musks or 10 bernie sanders
i'm curious not even a question i'm
curious what you think because your
argument is the fact that
one is talking about let's go on space
and the other one is talking about let's
fix the problem here
what would you say yeah i mean if it
clearly elon musk
why though tell me why jobs productivity
commerce i agree but that's not
at the same time bernie sanders can have
some valid points
it's not like it's it's a zero-sum game
where it's like
you either go elon or bernie do i agree
with taxing the wealthy and doing and
universal health care and all that that
bernie wants
i don't agree with all of that but do i
agree that
income inequality is a problem do i
67 percent of americans live paycheck to
paycheck
and something needs to be done even the
economic country in the world
and this is the right almost 70 percent
of our people have paycheck to paycheck
but whose fault is that though we have
so much of like
here's the challenge man let me tell you
what the biggest challenge is with this
and
it's it's very frustrating that we have
a hard time like
when i get a call and they tell me what
my son did wrong
okay like let's just say i get a call
from school and they tell me what my son
they're wrong i got a great relation
with the school in the
dallas prison piece phenomenal shout out
to ms porter i trusted that woman a lot
she did it the right way okay and we put
all our kids there private school
phenomenal place we had a great time
with them
when we left one of the biggest factors
that we didn't want to leave dallas was
the school
we loved the way they took care of our
kids at prince of peace and we're trying
to find something like that here
right but when i get a call and an email
will be sent
and the teacher would say here's how
your son reacted today he did this this
this that
i said great so i'd get on a call and i
would notice this teacher is reasonable
she's got a good point how do we work
together
can you and then i would say you can
tell my son this you can tell my son
this you can tell my son this will work
and can you please give me feedback when
i come out home at night guess what i'm
going to talk to the guy
and not sit down hey tickle can i talk
to you hey dylan can i talk to you
hey santa can i talk to you and we would
work to do what
to have discourse to to to to improve to
sit down and figure out ways to improve
right and figure out a way on what we
can do to
make it a better place i don't mind the
criticism that we give
to individuals like elon musk nothing
wrong with that
give it i have no problem with that but
one is
creating the other one is regulating
one is sitting there saying how can we
make something better
the other is sitting there saying how
can we slow this down one is saying
we kind of have to pay attention to
space on what's going on over there
because i don't know what's going to
happen over here
the other one is saying let's just fix
whatever we got going on today
one is thinking outside the box one just
wants to constantly
tax and regulate non-stop tax and
regulate non-stop
if we go into that direction it's going
to be very very problematic the
direction we're going right now
and what's so funny right now is
that tweet right there got tens of
thousands of retweets and likes
people are actually agreeing that's
what's scary about it
what's scary about it is that people are
sitting there saying oh wow this totally
makes sense
yeah we should do this
is there some common ground like if elon
musk and bernie sanders actually met
is it all or nothing you either got to
be full-on capitalist or full-on so
or could there actually be some well i
see your point here but you got to
understand if you tax this
okay cool i never considered that like
walk me through what a conversation and
actually some discourse how do you do
to find some common ground would be how
do you do that with an unreasonable
person
who's unreasonable you're saying you
think bernie is reasonable
i'm not saying that he's unreasonable
i'm not saying he's the most reasonable
no i'll say that he's under that would
never work you don't think he'd be
willing to listen
elon musk could come to that table
objectively and probably go
back and forth and maybe give a little
bit bernie sanders has a brand
and that's why he gets millions of likes
on his tweets because people think there
might be a little trickle-down effect
and they'll get some of that money from
elon musk that's all they care about
you know just spread it out so it's
it's zero percent burden no but bernie
has a zero percent
bill clinton was reasonable yep okay you
could sit there and newt and him figure
it out they'll go
okay uh uh uh what's the guy's name that
uh was the house of representatives
under reagan what was his name tip
o'neill
they sat down they fought it out but it
was reasonable tip o'neill
the one thing tip o'neill knew that
everybody knew about tip
they had in common they loved america
bernie doesn't love america
bernie loves russia bernie loves karl
marx
bernie loves socialism you don't think
bernie loves america absolutely not
really okay now now we're about to go
into a nice conversation here mr adam
what is america to you go ahead
sweetheart
um loaded question what is america it's
not it's not a loaded question
no no it's very simple for a guy like
danny iran i'm asking you what
could it like if you're asking from an
immigrant i mean no no i'm asking you
buddy adam sosnick what is america to
you
the the freedom to come and go as you
please
do what you want to life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness
to uh hopefully um
create what you want to create okay and
uh defend
the purpose of america okay um do you
think america
is at like the pinnacle like when was
america
stay on your point keep telling me what
you think america is i'm actually
curious you're you're basically saying
that bernie doesn't believe any of that
no you're not hearing what i'm saying
i'm asking you a question just go with
me like imagine this is foreplay and
just let me lead
okay this is a conversation conversation
you're turning me on yes i am so
hopefully the audience is being turned
on so
the audience likes good dialogue what
else is america too so far everything
you said i agree with you what else is
america too
hopefully uh a shining city on a hill
that uh
our good friend ronald reagan would talk
about um
and i think the problem is it's becoming
not
as much and from a bernie sanders point
of view not as much that
shining city let me ask you a question
let me ask you a question yes if i'm in
iran i'd love to be in america no
correct that's not but if i'm from
norway i'm thinking i don't know
maybe i'll stay in norway this is not
about norway or me i'm asking you
buddy i'm asking i'm focused on adam uh
give me one of the most loved admired
adored
presidents of all time on both sides of
the aisle that they love them
both sides of the aisle it's a very easy
name yeah lincoln obviously okay but
give me one that's in the last hundred
years
jfk jfk sure if i have to say moderate
democrat
who would you say the favorite right
wing to the left and the favorite left
wing to the right who are the two names
jfk and who's the other guy you're
saying the two people that democrats
that were willing to tolerate the
republican and republicans that were
willing to
tolerate the democrat president can
somebody help me out here
was there jfk's wine and who's the other
republican that was loved reagan
okay those two names okay but let's say
jfk
jfk did two things he lowered the taxes
and he told them i'm not lowering the
taxes
just to lower taxes i'm lowering the
taxes so you can capitalize right now
and go make money
to take care of your families what did
jfk say he said don't ask what
your country can do for you what's good
you can do for your country okay
so then he said we should go land where
on the freaking moon baby do you realize
everything of what jfk say bernie
sanders doesn't stand for
so a democrat who is listening right now
your buddy bernie sanders hates what jfk
stood for
let me say this one more time so jfk
who's a star comes in he says oh
let's go land on the moon this guy's a
freaking nut case
dude what are you talking about land on
the moon that doesn't matter today we
should land on the moon why
we should go land on them what for
because the 13 year old kid needs to
believe we can land on the moon and he
believes
because the future innovators of america
are just being born today and we need to
inspire them
we should lower taxes why lower taxes
it's not fair
we should raise taxes because we need
help we need social programs
don't ask what the country can do for
you ask what you can do for your country
bernie sanders
who cares about going on the moon and
going to you know space
who cares do you should tell about what
the country should do for you we should
raise taxes dude he would hate jfk today
forget about trump
enemy the state number one for bernie is
jfk
so you got to be kidding me so you say
you love america you don't love america
you don't love america you love the
ideas that you would want america to
adopt but that's not america
that's bernie america that's not america
so
adam this is such a critical thing here
because
philosophically when one idea shifts
there are sure there are certain like
you ever heard the thing
uh uh uh in too deep you remember how
you see you know when you're in too deep
or the tipping point of being into a
deep like for example let's just say you
and i are going to a club
okay we're driving a car and i said adam
let's go we're going to go my friend
a friend's a van you get in a van okay
the guy says hey guys oh sh let me tell
you guys something just happened right
now what's that
i got uh 100 pounds of kilo on the back
and everybody can you guys just grab a
gun right now
the guy the cocaine i just got right now
you know i just got it from this guy
it's in the back of the truck dude i'm
like these guys are chasing us i don't
know what the hell to do
it's a red light okay one guy says dude
i'm getting out
you're in the car what are you gonna do
tuck and roll are you gonna get out are
you gonna stay in the car honestly
there's a there's guns there's a hundred
kilos
we're going to miami we're on our way to
spring break we're gonna go to miami
yeah
i go into the car with one of my friends
one of my friends brings his friend that
i'm not friends with
this guy all of a sudden i find that
he's got 100 kilos of cocaine in the
back
yeah i'm not getting an uber i'm good
i'll meet you one guy gets out what are
you doing
there's a red light one guy says dude
i'm out what are you doing
probably leaving with that guy okay but
if you don't get out
and he goes in and the three cars pull
up you're officially in too deep
what's gonna happen there give me the
best case scenario what's the best case
scenario that happens if the bad guys
are chasing you
if the cops chase us what's the best
case scenario
what's the best case not worst case stop
a plea i mean you get arrested you maybe
try to get a lighter sentence
you get free but no matter what you're
in 2d yeah right you had the chance to
get out at the red light but you didn't
very simple we are at the red light
and people can get out and they better
get out
because they're going to get arrested
and some crimes
on your credit will hurt you for the
rest of your life
certain decisions have consequences not
just one year
certain decisions have decades of
consequences and setbacks
america has to be listening up and
realizing
you need to get off the bus right now
sounds juicy sounds exciting sounds
energetic bernie gets fired up and lit
up and fires
everybody up because he's got more
energy and people like oh my gosh i
believe
aoc gets it up she's fired up and people
like oh she's so persuasive
but i'm telling you right now the rest
of the world
has experienced this it doesn't work get
off the bus
we have to highlight who we want to see
as heroes because we want kids to be
like them
bernie does not love america buddy
not the way you do and you're center or
left
not the way you do not the way i do not
the way anybody loves america bernie
doesn't love that america yeah i think
it's okay to say
like me personally i'm offended by
bernie sanders he's i find him very
offensive with what he says because what
he's saying is wrong
i mean this country has proven that the
way they do it has worked it's why
people sacrifice everything to come here
and i'll tell you the people that are
most offended
by what's going on in this country and
the bernies and these
progresses of the world that we have
right now it's immigrants it's people
that have come to this country
to start a business to have a chance at
freedom that did it the right way
and they see this i mean they're they're
offended i have a really good friend
very good friend i was with my friday
night who's from bologna italy speaks
fluid italian you'd think you're in
italy when you're with him
great businessman he imports stone
directly from
uh italy does a very very good business
in the united states
but he's disgusted by what's going on
here and think about it guys like him
you know they left their whole family
there they came here to start all over
because of what america was it was that
hope it was that dream that you can do
anything here and the government will
stay out of your way
okay that's what america is and now
they're trying to do everything they can
to get in your way and it's offensive
and bernie is wrong
adam you want to plea well look give us
the argument
i just want to set the record straight
i've never voted for bernie i'm not a
bernie bro
i'm not a bernie supporter but i think
it would be wrong to dismiss
everything he ever says and just
unequivocally say he
does not love america and he hates
america because some of the math
i'm not again i'm not supporting bernie
i'm giving the other side
to his argument there's no one here
supporting bernie so someone's got to do
it for this argument you know some of
the numbers he talks about
7 out of 10 workers are living paycheck
to paycheck
billionaires over the pandemic 660
billionaires
their wealth went up over a trillion
dollars the 50
wealthiest americans have more money
than the bottom
half of our society the top like bernie
always says the top one
tenth of one to one percent have more
than 90
of our entire country so ceos are making
320 percent this is a dan price
reference
320 percent more than the average worker
so if i'm an average worker
and i make 45 grand a year and i'm
thinking man
i i can't i got two kids i can't get
ahead
i hear taxes may go up on the super
wealthy making 400 grand i'm making 45
grand
this guy bernie sounds like he knows
what he's talking about i'm put again
i'm putting myself in the shoes of the
person making
45 grand a year nobody is it's an
intoxicating argument
that's all i'm saying here's here's a
how many parents okay remember the story
i was telling about tico and the kids if
they go to school teacher says something
certainly that's that's that's that's
that's you know you're making 45 grand a
year about no but but
she chose to he chose nobody told him to
be a teacher
what i'm saying to you have a choice
that's your choice okay you chose to
choose a get summarized fashion career
okay and by the way there's benefits to
being a teacher i mean there's a lot of
benefits to being a teacher
you ain't doing it for money all good
for the record i think teachers should
be paid more that's just my
uh i don't disagree but i also think uh
50 of teachers should be fired and
the other top twenty percent should get
a fifty percent rate but i don't think
he'll detention
or [ __ ] they should get fired i
think half the teachers should be part
of america and they need to be treated
like we get treated
if i don't do the right thing i get
fired and i think teachers should be
fired as well so let me give you we're
going somewhere
i'm going somewhere with this because
you're talking about seven out of ten
people are living paycheck to paycheck
okay
all of these percent the top one percent
owns more than that yeah
okay i all of those things bernie's
argument but that's not an argument
those are statistics
corrupt that's the thing somebody just
said something right now the guy gave
five bucks
and uh bishman said pbd you and bernie
both love america but have different
ways to solve the problems in america to
say someone doesn't love america because
they disagree with bs
i disagree with you bishman because to
me america is just a name
okay to me america is an idea so if you
don't love the ideas of america you
don't love america
that's what it means to me okay because
america to me if they change the idea i
don't like america
i don't this makes sense to you guys or
not it's very simple like you know you
can
you can flip if somebody changes their
views and for example let's just say
you loved your cousin okay you sincerely
love your cousin
and your cousin was a guy with values
and principles your cousin flips
he goes and becomes a drug dealer he
goes and kills a few people and he does
do you you don't you don't stand for the
same thing the values and principles
change i'm sorry i'm not going to sit
there and say
hey go have my kids hang out with you so
let's go back to the 70
of people that are living paycheck to
paycheck yes that is statistic
the question then becomes how we go
about fixing it there's two ways
you have to put the pressure on the
people to take responsibility
or you put the pressure on who the
government or you put the pressure on
rich people
okay in this situation he wants to put
the pressure on who
the rich on the rich people not on the
government not on the people on the rich
people that's not what jfk would have
done and he's a democrat
and the most loved and adored democrat
of all time okay himself
he would have put the pressure and said
hey why don't you do something about it
i was watching an interview yesterday of
the shah with bbc
okay and this is the point where iran's
coming up
they're about to pass up uk okay and
he made a couple predictions that
interview was so powerful i don't know
who shared it with me i'm so glad this
one guy that was 27 minutes
and he said i am begging the word to use
this i'm begging
america to stop relying on oil he said
this on 75.
he says i'm begging america to stop
relying on oil the west to stop relying
on oil
but he says one of the problems with uk
is what you know what he says one of the
problems with uk's
he says you guys are too lazy you take
way too many sleeping pills
you guys are too lazy you don't work
that hard he says if your government
got the average worker to work one hour
more
a day your economy will change since i'm
not saying five more hours
if they work one more access if you work
30 minutes more a day
your economy will change rather than a
bernie sanders saying no stay home
it's not fair it's mental issues you're
having
we all have meant i have mentally i've
mentally issues my entire life i have
emotional issues we all have mental and
emotional issues
none of us are robots but rather than
saying that you say hey johnny question
for you what's your dream
i want to be able to live xyz life great
when do you want to have that 10 years
why don't you for the next 10 years
start a side gig make the money save the
money invest the money the right way 10
years from now go live your dream with
your wife and kids
why don't you do that but we're not
talking about that it's we
can solve your problems anytime the
government comes in using the word help
run who said that not reagan a long time
ago go ahead
okay one last point here is you know
just like bernie sanders
is popular with what he says but just
because he's popular doesn't mean he's
wrong
right and he is wrong and there's
evidence that okay you just take money
from the rich and you hand it out
i'll give you a perfect example if you a
story we've already done today at
vtpost.com
bank of america has done some research
and some polling to find out what people
are spending their stimulus checks on
right the fourteen hundred dollars has
already gone out can you pull it up yeah
it's one of the stories on vtp.com right
now um you know what they're finding
people are spending it on shoes and
apparel i mean that is one of the main
things so
there's no direct correlation between
what bernie's saying and that the
country gets better
there is ample evidence of the opposite
and that's why i am so offended by his
message because it doesn't work
and it's it's it's become you know
almost to the point where you're not
allowed to say that because you don't
care
or you don't have feelings for people
that's not true and i just
he's got what does it say it says the
newly somewhat
rich by 1400 combined spending on
parallel athletic footwork jumped 19 and
a half percent year over year for the
week
ending march 12 what a recent comparison
how about the fact that with the same
parameters that spending was up 13.2
percent a week prior stimulus payments
began to hit consumer by the in the
account march 12th
or other avenues for spending including
addressing vision uh correction concerns
and this form of mojo.com poll responded
if i can i'd also like to pay off my
credit card that it's small and maybe
get on utilities and phone accounts see
people can be responsible the money is
okay
interesting to see this thing taking
place where the money is going to i mean
all they're doing is making nike richer
so phil knight is sitting there saying
send more
stimulus checks there's also been some
other stories that we covered this on
the podcast that
um and millennials are putting money
yeah 40 something percent of millennials
are taking their stimulus checks and
putting in the stock market
some absurd number and then the second
stat hold on hold on
uh in 2009 and 2020 were the only
years that the credit card debt has gone
down in america meaning people have took
their stimulus
and paid off credit cards that's not
because of stimulus that's because of
par
partially it's because of shutdown but
the first point you just made
that's what i agree with okay like you
see what you just did
we're making heroes of the kid that's
taking money investing it thinking long
term
that's not what bernie's doing no but
that's not what bernie's doing
bernie's solution is let me solve it for
you because i can solve it for you
not the entrepreneur and not yourself
you're not good enough
to solve this on your own 70 percent i
don't think you can help yourself
because i'm more elite
i'm smarter than you but i'll help you
out don't worry do you know what an
insult it is to think
that you are the one that can solve my
problems and not me
it's an insult that's that's the highest
level of eliteness
versus to say i think you can i think
you can do something about it
i think you can do something about it i
think you think i can do something i
think you can do something about it
we need more politicians saying hey
american people i think you can do
something about it i believe in you here
i have one last thing and
for all both of you guys do you think
maybe adam has a different perspective
on things because he's lived in florida
and texas
where you haven't lived in a state where
you really see
an overbearing government and extremely
high taxes and what that does to
day-to-day life
do you is that a possibility do you
think that maybe i think to flip it when
you said have you partied in miami
before you kind of spooked him i think
that's a very fair assessment to put it
on you
you've not lived in other states to kind
of get a feel of what it looks like when
there's over regulation
correct you've lived in a i live in
florida my majority of my heaven on
earth
not saying you're not well traveled
you've been all over them i've been all
over all over the world
my favorite city is new york city by the
way i i would say that as well
i i don't i don't dispute that i think
florida although florida is starting to
become
one of my favorites so to visit but um
yeah everything comes down to
perspective so i i agree with you on
that i mean
like i always ask you when you move in
lla when you move in la you rail against
california rail against l.a
you love it there you go your family
loves it there you're supporting
california what i'm saying like you love
it they're so
you take the good with the bad just a
quick point on our friend elon musk
and this is more of just a teen it up
for you you know he's been
speaking of bernie and elon and this
whole how this whole conversation got
started
you know that elon has been very much in
favor of ubi
he's come out and said i don't believe
in bailing out companies and
and you know helicopter payments so
wherever
i actually believe in giving money to
the people ubi elon musk has said this
so it's very ironic because there's some
parts that bernie and this is why i
asked that question what's his challenge
what's elon musk's challenge with that
if you're asking me ask me the question
what's the challenge with what elon musk
thinks as well
that we need ubi okay where are you
going with that what's the challenge
with elon musk
go ahead he thinks he's smarter than the
rest of the world
yeah like he thinks he is no i don't i
disagree he
thinks that none to be of course he is
smarter to be worth a couple hundred
billion dollars
but he thinks people cannot make money
on their own
to go find solutions survivor
survivor of the fittest man we've been
we've been surviving for a very
long time we've we figured out a way how
to survive past these animals and these
animals all these animals were all
afraid of guess what
we won just so you know the lions
all the the tigers the bears but you're
laughing about it
you realize we won
we won i don't know if you realize we
overcame all of that
we overcame all these viruses without
having any solutions we figured it out
we figured out all these solutions we
forget
we figured out how to create something
like this i don't even know how to
create something like that
we figured out how to create this how
the hell do we figure this out i don't
know a lion didn't figure this out we
did
we figured out how to put this tripod
what the hell is this ipad doing in
front of me i'm looking at myself
talking there's
three thousand something people watching
how the hell do we figure this out how
do we figure this out right how do we
figure all these how do we figure this
out how do we do this
human ingenuity what i'm trying to tell
you is we have to trust in the human
ingenuity just because elon
is ubi that doesn't mean we're all
sitting here saying well because elon
musk said it it's right i don't this
i don't agree with that so anyways
having said that let's continue so
if you're watching this by the way we
had a couple people jk win gave 10
they said there was an international
student focus group and they said they
were turned off by how
the u.s is going and don't want to come
here anymore what are your thoughts okay
uh and then matthew elliott said five
dollars best long-form podcast on
youtube great subject matter thoughtful
responses and just the right
amount of civil discourse by the way if
you want to ask a question
for us to address go on twitter send
your tweet pbd podcast hashtag
once again put the hashtag pbd podcast
and we will address a couple of them
here in a minute so kaif you're looking
at it
send your tweet with hashtag pbdpodcast
kai is monitoring that and if you're
enjoying it so far press the thumbs up
button
and for some of you guys that haven't
subscribed yet many of you are watching
this thinking this is valuetainment this
is a complete separate channel please
press the subscribe button
so you get alerts and click that
notification button so you're one of the
first to come up
and uh we're uh we're hope to have you
uh be with us in the future to get this
thing to a hundred thousand subscribers
okay
putin challenges biden to debate
after the president calls him a killer
russian president vladimir putin has
reacted to president joe biden calling
him a killer by challenging biden to
take part
in a conversation with him broadcast
live online putin told a russian state
television reporter
i just started this now i want to
propose to president biden to continue
our discussion but on the condition that
we do it basically live
as it's called without any delays
and directly in an open direct
discussion it seems to me that would be
interesting for the people of russia
and for the people of united states
biden said he thought putin was a killer
russia recalled its ambassador to the
united states in
response to the remark after issuing his
invitation putin said he did not
he didn't want to delay i don't want to
put this off for long i want to go
this tiger this weekend to relax a
little
so we could do it tomorrow or monday we
are ready
at any time convenient for the american
side
the russian leader also said he wished
biden good health
i would say to him be well i wish him
good health i say that without any irony
without any jokes
adam the truth is there was some irony
and full-on jokes there with putin
um look there's two sides you can kind
of look at this there's the side that
it's like bro what are you doing
like you don't put your [ __ ] out there
and just like reveal your hand
and completely disrespect a world leader
you kind of do it
behind closed doors or you have a little
more diplomacy or
tact um but then there's the other side
that's like
let me just spit the truth and actually
say what the truth is
putin is a killer whether it's on the
micro level or the macro level micro
he's poisoning his
dissidents or pointing people poisoning
to speak out about him he's
former kgb on a macro level he's
invaded other countries um ukraine
um what's the city in ukraine that i'm
thinking of the main area in ukraine
that
they're fighting about help me out here
not kiev
what is it called i don't know the place
in ukraine anyway
he's gone into ukraine he's done um
foreign affairs so the point is which
direction do you want to go do you want
to have diplomacy do you want to have
tact or do you want to tell the truth
and for me biden has to have a balance
of both am i
completely turned off that he would say
something like this
no do i completely agree that he went
this direction
and called out putin on tv not as much
but what i do know
is after the reality show president
donald trump
um a putin biden argument uh debate on
tv would be
reality tv of the highest magnitude
um so we'll see where this goes here but
uh
i um i'm not i'm not sold on either
direction of what biden went here
you know i i think the comment calling
putin a killer just shows how naive
biden is when it comes to foreign
affairs i mean there was just nothing
to gain with with a with a comment like
that especially someone like putin who
would eat his lunch
just on every conceivable level you know
the way he's manipulating him now with
the comeback
you don't want to challenge a guy like
that because what if he is a killer what
if he is that
crazy i mean these guys can do hacks at
the drop of a hand he could probably
shut down our
electrical grid if he wanted to i think
a little bit more tact in dealing with
with putin would make a little bit more
sense you know you talk about trump
being the loose cannon but
he didn't really have any outburst like
this
you know most of it was now some people
didn't agree with how he dealt with um
north korea and got a little bit too
cozy with him but
i don't know was he trying to be funny
was he trying to be light was he trying
to be tough
i just didn't think there was anything
to gain by what biden did and i think
it's completely backfired on him
well here's the thing once you become a
president you have to understand one
thing
is john gotti you know who john gotti is
right okay when i interviewed samuel
garvano i asked him about john gotti i
said
uh oh john another guy interviewed
elight said the fact that
john gotti never killed anybody okay he
would always other people kill people
for him
and sami stops me and interrupts like as
if and sammy was
like they're not in the best place with
john gotti but sammy interrupts and just
kind of says let me tell you something
you crossed john gotti he was capable he
says
you know he was capable of doing
anything i don't know if i've ever seen
him kill anybody or not the story about
the dentist i don't know
but you don't want to cross john because
he was capable right
would you consider john gotti a killer
yes
but what if he never killed anybody but
he told other people to kill people is
he considered
i think so absolutely so if you tell
somebody else to kill somebody
to defend your your territory would you
be considered a killer
i think so yes then every president is a
killer
okay so if that's the qualification you
just made
you just send troops to syria you're
officially qualified killer
okay if that's your interpretation okay
on where you went with that
trump would be like what do you think
america is so innocent yeah famously
what i'm trying to say to you is once
you become a president
you have to know you're in the gray area
for four years you're the
commander-in-chief
you're the commander-in-chief so if you
can't sit there and be like oh my gosh
he's such a this
look you can't you're not an angel when
you become a president
you can't be nobody is not a single one
of our presidents ever has been an angel
some have more more higher morals and
values some less
but the reality is you have to be
willing to call the shots now
was putin one before he became possibly
and that's the reputation possibly kgb
what i'm saying possibly i don't know
i've just read the articles and it says
that he was
okay do you think putin's a killer
i think i've told you this when trump
was president i think putin's the
most brilliant strategist president
powerful person in the world today it's
not the u.s commander-in-chief just so
you know this i put putin at number one
putin is a genius strategist
not more than she right now would he be
no she has more power putin
is a better strategist putin to me is a
street trained this is the the right guy
you want
here's the analogy for putin yeah by the
way crimea was the city in
um ukraine putin's you know if you're
playing a poker game
and we all have a hand putin's playing
with like a pair of sixes
like uh an offsuit three you know maybe
like a jack and
you know like a ten like there's no hand
yeah but he makes you think he's dealing
with like
pocket jacks and pockets queens or
something like that you know what
country has the most nuclear weapons
right now
america okay can you pull up nuclear
bombs real quick
or is it russia can you just pull it up
to what the leaders bulletin says i like
data
that's what i like i like numbers and
data countries
with most there you go click on that
nuclear
click on that put the list
hopefully it's as updated as possible is
there a way to go leaders bulletin okay
russia
right there look look go back up go back
up kai
russia 6 375 u.s 5800 i think you don't
want to screw with russia
okay just so you know china's only got
320. let's face it if russia wanted to
destroy the world and just leave an
island called russia
okay he could do it isn't it one another
he would be he would be
they would be you know how they say like
why is american military so strong well
you know
um a strong military prevents war
prevents war exactly
like a strong budget let me let me go
back to what what biden said
in this interview okay uh he's talking
to stephanopoulos
okay they're going back and forth
they're talking about a bunch of
different things but he says
uh he will pay a price okay we had a
long
talk biden says he and i
when we i know him relatively well and
the conversation started off i said
i know you and you know me if i
establish this
accord uh then be prepared
stephanopoulos says so you know vladimir
putin
you think he's a killer um i do
okay you'll see that putin is going to
pay
okay this is what biden says he
continues
waking chew gum at the same time for
places where it's our own mutual
interest to work together
okay so he then says i looked at him in
the eyes
and says i know who you are okay what do
you mean i know who you are
like i know who you are so he's saying
this about putin about a private
conversation that he had with them
um you tell me what other president
prime minister of another country will
trust having a private conversation with
biden moving
forward so one there's recording of you
10 years ago 15 years ago talking about
if you don't fire that lawyer or that
whoever it is
we're not going to give you the money
that's recorded that's on video
billions of people have seen that you
know which ones i'm talking about where
you know which one i'm talking about
where he's sitting there
so he said it okay biden biden when he
says if you're ukraine
what is it yeah the ukraine is going to
cut them off if you don't fire this
person
we're going to cut you off you're not
going to get the money right so we know
how this guy works
okay so in this game
not only did putin win but america lost
because officially no one in the world
is going to trust talking to biden
off camera the safest place to talk to
biden right now is only one place with
cameras on
and guess who's going to do it nobody
the only people that are going to do it
is they'll talk to us
in administration here's the other part
say you're an advisor you're like a
biden's
jim baker james baker your bidens
whoever just pick one of them right
karl rove your biden's uh any of those
names
what do you think you're telling about
you know what i'm telling biden bro
seriously just kick back you know what i
mean
let her do the talking let somebody else
do the talking dude
nothing and when you're walking up the
stairs we're going to turn off the
camera
when you're going out there having any
kind of questions cut it short
we're going to see you have another
meeting we're going to keep telling
everybody you've got a meeting just
don't do any of this publicity stunts
when a guy publicly calls you out to a
meeting
it's like this say there's a thousand
high school
lunch cafeteria 100 kids are there
and you tell me you know what f you
i'm like what oh okay
meet me behind the bungalows after
school okay nice 100
yeah meet me meet me behind the bunkles
after school
and i said okay 100 kids just saw me
three o'clock comes you're behind the
bungalows
i'm going home who am i the next day in
school
coward no no i'm a coward putin
called biden to go behind the bungalow
everybody went to the bungalow looking
forward to putin to see biden there
what do you think are the chance of
biden saying yes to putin
honestly zero one in what one in a
thousand
one in a million one in a billion is it
more are you saying that just because
putin called him out he should do it
oh i i i don't think if you don't do it
you got first of all
when in the history of the diplomacy
have you seen another person saying
i want to have a live conversation with
you with the world watching when has
that ever happened never
when has that ever happened so so one a
person has the audacity to say that
because they know you're going to say
what
no i'm not coming they know you're going
to say no they know you're going to say
no of course they're going to say no so
now you turn it down and it's not like
it's a podcaster
saying hey biden i want you to come
forward if you nobody gives a [ __ ]
it's not like it's a congressman it's
not like it's a mayor of uk
it's not like it's a senator no no it's
the currently most powerful man in the
world just call you out to a duel
i got a big problem with it to be honest
with you because you've got to know
what your audience is and who you're
talking about can you imagine the level
of training
that vladimir putin putin has had as the
head of the kgb can you imagine the
negotiating skills the
the mental games that he can play with
people he's toying with biden right now
and for him that's just it just shows a
naivete
that's a little bit troubling to me in
the first couple months that he's doing
this the other thing he said the other
day that was troubling
is he referred to kamala harris as
president harris i mean he's making a
few
stumbles and bumbles here that are it
it's
it's playing into the narrative well
there's a joke there i figured you'd
segue this she is the president well no
i'm saying it's playing into a narrative
that a lot of people foresee happening
where this is segueing into you know is
he even capable of having these
discussions i think he thinks he can get
away with some of this
grandiose bravado and it's going to slip
off to the side but i mean
putin just went right at him and just
toyed with him on this
i think you know as much as i do not
think that that biden is a
classic strategist or anything like that
there has to be a conscious effort to
say look under trump
he was clearly cozying up to putin i
mean whether you
agree with trump or don't agree or trump
he would not call out russia
or putin whatsoever he was causing up to
dictators with kim jong-un
he was making enemies how many wars did
we have did you go to sleep ever
worrying
how many wars did we have under trump
this bad terrible human being how many
wars do we have
how was diplomacy do we have under obama
no
how many wars do we have under obama one
was the isis award in afghanistan
no that happened under bush every day
you turned on the news it was isis
you forgot like how old are you you're
40 years old where'd it say
every day we saw isis how many times you
heard isis during trump
how many times you heard about people
down all you heard about is protesting
and riots
all you heard about is problems here
look don't you know if you watch my
podcast
i got a lot of trump people that can't
stand me right now because of what i've
said on the last few comments
but i'm consistent with my views on what
i believe with this
but if you if you're going to give the
argument of war
give the argument uh i didn't give the
argument a warrant you brought up war no
you believe i'm just saying he was
closing up the dictators well that's why
he was do you though why do you what
why do you build those relationships so
you don't have wars
okay you don't you don't make peace with
your friends in his book
lincoln on leadership said the fastest
way to eliminate an enemy is to what
turn him into a friend okay this is the
greatest president of all time there's
some genius in it maybe he read that
book maybe biden needs to read that book
maybe biden needs to go by donald t
phillips book called linking on
leadership
and read one of the rules of lincoln
what sentiment copy
yeah let's send them off at the white
house okay so so all this stuff you're
saying listen i'm not
sitting here saying trump is the goat
and all this other stuff
no at all i'm not saying that i'm not
saying that at all all i'm saying is
in this area i have gone to sleep
worried about war for 10 years of my
life let's say eight years of my life
because first two years you don't even
know what it means but three years old
in iran you kind of know some shit's
going down
right when you go out there your parents
are explaining that's what happened over
there
it's not cool it's scary and that fear
didn't go away for a long time
as a kid you're always like paranoid
right when i got to the states i went to
the army
you know it went away a little bit and
then it's kind of gradually gone away
because america 911 kind of brought back
a little bit saying
this [ __ ] can get pretty pretty bad but
i love the fact that we have a strong
military and we are where we are
okay i love i love the fact that you
don't wake up in the morning hearing
about osama bin laden you don't hear
about isis which
credit i that was an obama thing but you
don't hear about isis
that went away under trump fully
he should have never done that what did
you hear about iran retaliating
nothing they were afraid of them now
iran doesn't even want to sit down and
have a conversation with biden's people
why they would have never done that with
trump so
there are ways you have to know that a
a human being that may be
the way that he was you were safer
during that time
just telling you so this approach here
you just pissed off the most powerful
guy in the world
i'm telling you and and the worst kind
of wars you want is proxy wars and that
guy's a genius of proxy wars
genius and not only pissed him off
offended him i mean i think the last
thing you'd want to call putin is a
killer
i mean literally i mean i think that's
the one word that he would be most upset
about and be planning
you know some sort of so are we
responsible this is me just throwing
this out there
are we saying that we cannot piss off
putin at all
no not at all say some [ __ ] to putin or
is that where we're at right now yeah
but what
we can't say about what he did bro if
you call somebody a killer diplomacy is
gone yo listen conor mcgregor goes and
does his
shenanigans with two mayweather
mayweather doesn't give a [ __ ] because
mayweather wants what the payday
he got it 300 million dollars conor guy
what a hundred million dollars
he tried to do the same thing with
khabib do you know what happened with
that fight
he called that his religion he called
that his family he called us
do you know khabib wasn't fighting conor
he was defending his philosophies and
guess who was on khabib's side
a guy named putin you know what he did
to counter do you know what he did after
he beat counter
he jumped over the cage chased other
people his people got in
you don't call out certain people like
that
biden called that the person that's the
most sensitive with words like this
you have to be very careful with that oh
you think putin is sensitive about that
not sensitive sensitive in a
in a way where uh uh like you know mom
jokes in america people tell mom jokes
try to tell a mom joke to an armenian
yeah it doesn't sit while we're on
armenia i'm actually being very serious
with you
i don't like mom jokes i will never tell
mom jokes to you you mean like those yo
mama jokes in my lifetime i've never
told your mama joke to anybody did it
the other day
i would never say it to you i would
never say to you yeah you can say
he's saying there's certain lines you
can cross with certain people you tell a
yo mama joke to an armenian the armenian
has no clue what the hell you're talking
about
he's like what did you like i'm telling
you it's very very you say about mama
you can't say in armenia you can't tell
an armenian
mama jokes right now an americanized one
maybe a different story you just crossed
the line with a guy like this so we're
going to see what's going to happen
we're going to see what's going to
happen with that by the way
quick shout out with kanye west it came
out that he's the richest man in the
world 6.6 billion richest black richest
black men in america
in america yes 6.6 billion then it came
back and they said forbes king came back
and said well it's not really 6.6
billion
it's 1.8 billion uh robert smith is
really still the richest black man in
america at 6 billion
vista equities then the nigerian aliko
is worth 11.8 billion but the reality is
the yeezy brand is valued at 3.2 to 4.7
billion dollars let me say that one more
time
the yeezy brand is valued at 3.2
to 4.7 billion dollars you know the
other day he announced his shoes at 200
you know it sold out by 7 a.m fully sold
by 7am can you imagine how crazy that is
people bought the shoes and flipped it
for 400 the same day on ebay
okay so what do you think about what
kanye's got going on okay this is a
really
really fascinating story i think the
person that's probably offended the most
is jay-z
is as hard as he's worked how many
different things he's involved in and to
think that he has to look up to kanye
west on wealth i guarantee you this is
pissing off
jay-z in a big way i also find it also
very ironic that
he has elevated himself allegedly to
being the most
wealthiest or the richest black person
in america from shoes
right that he's had for what seven eight
years and michael jordan has built
a much bigger brand with shoes owns an
nba team and he has passed him up that
quickly
by the way michael is nike yeezy is
adidas
and gap now that was a brilliant move
putting their shoes into gap and getting
kids exposed to it young
so now if you peel back a little bit
here there's some smoke and mirrors
going on with this stuff because
i think it was bloomberg first that
reported this story and then forbes
carved it up and chopped it up and said
it's complete bs you're not worth 6.6
billion so
remember what happened with kylie jenner
right when forbes put her on the cover
as being the first or the youngest
self-made billionaire
in the world right and then it came out
a little bit later that maybe
kris kardashian had been fudging some of
that and they felt that they got used a
little bit
so forbes is incredibly pissed off i
think at the kardashian family
even though kanye is exiting it you know
eventually here
i think this has something to do with a
little bit payback you know to go back
there and look at that story and try to
discredit it
because of how they were burned with a
kardashian number in the past so
i think there's some of that with forbes
involved here and bloomberg and forbes
you look at as the bible as the gospel
when it comes to personal wealth like
that
they've got a cottage industry of
ranking the richest people in the world
but
this has got so many layers it's
fascinating it's the kardashians
it's shoes it's nike it's rich it's
adidas
but i think there's something to be said
about a personal battle between forbes
and kris kardashian and the extension of
her and that family you're into this
story
yeah i just find it not really i find it
ups and downs and curves
um with kanye i'm not saying she's a
gold digger but
shame missing with a broke socialist
uncapitalist type of person i mean
when's the last time you shop at the gap
the fact that he's bringing the gap
to relevancy next thing you know he
might do a deal with abercrombie and
fitch i feel like it's the 90s again
but uh obviously a brilliant dude um
polarizing guy and go get your money
kanye obviously he's single now
so i don't think he's gonna have a um a
shortage of
suitors it's kind of a semi-genius would
you put him as a semi-genius yeah yeah
personally i would just with his
creativity yeah i mean he has
he owns that brand 100 he owns the whole
thing and he's got final say on all
creative decisions so i think he is a
genius
to come up with a brand that sells like
that now we don't know what the volume
is right they might produce
a pretty low number so it does sell out
rather quickly which i'm sure is the
case
but he is a genius he's created this i
think he's got
um confidence of the highest
magnitude that even like most people are
like oh you're crazy bro he's like
yeah i am that's right and he just
embraces the craziness and
i mean he's been he's been to he's got
mental anxiety and you know all sorts of
stuff going on
but yeah i think you know musically
music sick his ideas uh you can't tie
that guy down i mean
kim who never who knows what happened
with that by the way i think
i i think kanye uh is battling with
something right now
this my opinion okay i tell you what
he's battling with right now tell us
i think he's battling with what has he
experienced today so think about it
here's a guy that's produced some of the
greatest hip-hop you know
songs he's crushed incredible albums
where the world would listen to it
he has done well as an entrepreneur he's
married to modern-day marilyn monroe
whether you're like her or not
kim kardashian is the modern day i don't
know who you put ahead of her as a
marilyn monroe we've talked about this
before
so at what level hasn't he reached who
has he partied with who hasn't he
partied with he's been to the trump
he's been to the white house he's met
presidents he's met prime minister he's
done everything right
i think he's at a point right now where
for him the battle is do i continue
being this famous powerful person making
money making products
or do i go after purpose i think this
guy can really
have a massive impact in the world with
how he himself grew as an individual and
i don't know what's going to happen with
that
but i own a domain called kanyakan okay
i bought for him kanya khan that
i would love for kanye to be a guest on
the podcast
even here or on valuetainment to
interview him because there are some
questions i want to ask him that no
one's ever asked and i'd like to be able
to ask that of him and i want to kind of
go deeper on the way he processes issues
and how he views certain things but in
order to get that domain i'd love to
have a sit down with him anybody who
knows
how to get a hold of this man i'd love
to have a meeting
with i would love that kanye i think the
world
would appreciate i don't think the right
interview with him has been done yet i
don't think the right interview has been
done with him yet he's been on a lot of
different platforms
but the right interview has been done
with i once won nine dollars from kai
okay was it nine dollars or a dollar i
don't know what ten dollars what was the
number
nine dollars i won nine dollars ten
dollars no nine nine dollars yeah kai
loves giving me money like i wouldn't
bet
i love he's giving me money it's just a
threshold
no but that wasn't a bet that was if i
say it that's not a bet i never said i'm
betting you so it's a
was that the joe rogan yeah joe rogan he
thought it was gonna be bigger than elon
musk i said i don't know about that i
just think
kanye needs uh oh and joe did a good job
with that interview i just think i have
philosophical questions for this guy
not just entertaining questions yeah i
want to go deeper like he told me you
want to be challenged too by that
yeah i want that kind of a conversation
with the but listen more power to him
you brought up the purpose um with kanye
i mean
you've clearly seen some sort of shift
over the last
few years with kanye that it was all
music and then it turned into fashion
and over the last
really couple of years it's been church
and politics
and you know he used to you know come
from chicago and
and doing his thing with jay-z in new
york and
you know in the studio doing his thing
now he's living on a freaking ranch in
wyoming
and he's doing sunday churches and
kanye's sunday service and
obviously he was running for president
major air quotes going on there if
you're listening just
audio um i think he's finding his
purpose and i think
i don't think he's joking wrong when he
says he's running for president by the
way i think he's that sick in the head
he think he could actually he's not sick
in the head i don't think he's sick in
the head i think he's that much driven
by purpose yeah i don't mean sick in the
head in the negative way but like
crazy enough okay yeah here's the other
thing once he aligned with
god you know having his sunday services
and he supported trump and he wore the
maga hat you know
he got turned on by the mainstream media
so they're throwing out there that that
you know bipolar depression that you
know all the mental
aspects of is he crazy this kind of
thing yeah he's crazy rich that's what
he is
and i think he's really toying with the
media exactly how he wants to
um i would imagine and you can already
tell that it's going to be at least on
paper or at least the way it looks is
going to be an amicable divorce with kim
i mean it looks like you know with that
many kids involved and that much money
that they're going to get through this
thing
pretty uh you know peacefully so yeah i
think i think the media now because of
where he's aligned himself
you know just with his christian values
and the fact that politically he's not
just buying into everything that the
left
wants him to he's going to be targeted
and he's going to be painted as kind of
a villain
so you got to like read through some of
these headlines in mainstream media
yeah i mean wish him all the best are
you a kanye west fan
i've uh yeah i would say i've always
been uh
and jennifer's always jennifer always
with you you know he's a very talented
guy
i i've watched watch every one of his
interviews whether he did the ellen
degeneres one where he stood up and
people like what the hell is wrong with
this guy whether it's the
uh big boy interview whether it's the
elon musk interview i just like the way
this guy thinks
i think people like that have to prop
have to be properly interviewed on the
way they process
issues i think the world can learn from
that that and by the way i think elon
musk also
uh is another guy that uh we have to get
deeper
on the way he thinks there's a there's a
there's a chippy side
to them where it's like you know you
poke and it's like then the magic comes
out like i think there's
anyways i think there's a there's a part
where they need to be interviewed
uh specifically with connie so i'm
curious to know what's gonna happen with
that and
every time there's an interview out
there i just enjoy every single one of
them because the guys
are fascinating so a couple things spain
real quick i don't want to be on this
for too long spain tests out a four-day
work week spain is introduced in the
government approved for they work with
trial
with an aim to promote a better
work-life balance spain joins a number
of countries
in like new zealand sweden and japan to
promote longer weekend they argue that
working longer doesn't always mean
working better
the goal is to enroll 200 companies to
participate in the test run with up to 6
000 workers
the proposal a three or three year trial
running
starting this fall to shorten work weeks
which will cost nearly 60 million
dollars microsoft
piloted a four-day work week experiment
in japan in 2019
closing office on fridays and found
employees who sold nearly 40 more
for the company while it reduced
overhead spending cost similarly new
zealand the wealth management company in
new zealand perpetual guardian notice a
improvement of work when it allowed
employees to work for 32 hours per week
instead of 40 hours
cutting their pay in 2018 thoughts okay
my i have the same thought as the shah
of iran would uh four hours
so they're going to work more four days
a week they're they're ramping it up
isn't it yeah is it normally three days
in europe that's what it seems to me
that's the perception that the europeans
give that they
they take six weeks off to two months in
the summer that they work sorry kai
you can refute all this and you know
probably some of it's a stereotype but
when i heard four day work week i'm
going holy crap they're increasing their
workload
um anyway i like that study though
because
if microsoft did it they tried it and it
looks like it did have some success
i don't know i i'm a fan of people
coming to the office and working for the
most part in a corporate environment
i think it's not gonna work you know how
we've had to do it the past year i think
a lot of companies are realizing that
and we'll see it's a big case study here
it's a test
uh a big you know experiment and i don't
i don't know
i don't think it's gonna work i don't
think it's a great idea i think
something that the pandemic has
certainly brought to the forefront
is the uh work-life balance
um i think a lot of companies are you
know
i think companies again it's something
that i think this uh a theme of our
entire freaking podcast
is you know sensibilities
using um being reasonable and not being
too far right or too far left and i
think
you know your standard come to the
office five days a week 40 hour work
week that's it you're nine to five and
you're leaving 459 and you're part of
the 459 club
i think that's sort of an archaic model
at the same time i think certain
companies
um like salesforce and you know certain
silicon valley companies that are saying
yeah we're working remotely for the rest
of our lives all good
i think there doesn't need to be a
better work-life balance and
you know if a midday freaking siesta is
the cure to that or a 32-hour work week
or tim ferriss's four-hour work week you
know to to be a little ironic
or if it's hey i'm working freaking 80
hour work weeks but i love what i do
and i work from home um the key to work
and life is a a work-life balance so if
you can kind of find
um the middle ground life is work-life
balance i think so
dude you're like a philosopher yeah it's
like i feel like i feel honestly i feel
like if i smoke weed and listen to you i
would appreciate you
well why don't we do that why don't we
do that how do we do that okay
why don't we but you got to do me a
favor you got to bring some of that uh
initial foreplay we had in the uh oh i
will do
that a lot of that but uh okay all right
so
uh is spain right here are they wrong
here i think it's a test let's find out
what's going to happen the reality of it
is spain is already
you know destroying their entrepreneurs
to the point where the former prime
minister
president left the country because they
raised the taxes to god knows what
levels where he said i'm gonna go live
in a different place
they have so much data on countries like
this that it doesn't work they keep
doing it
and they keep doing it over and over and
over again so you know if they want to
test it out
but i like the way they're doing it
they're doing it with 200 companies only
6 000 employees it's only costing 60
million bucks a little at a test see
what happens yeah
as a ceo yeah do you have like a nope
this is the way it should be because you
got people out of different stores no i
i have off i have guys that that don't
want to run at the highest level and i'm
good with that
the only thing that would upset me is
when a person says they're going to do
something
and they do something else just be true
to what your vision and your goal is
it's very simple for me
not the other way around i'm about your
the weight behind your word
today i produced a video just went out
this morning at 8 45
eastern standard time the title is 15
qualities to be
part of an inner circle right i have
certain things people ask me
how can i be part of your inner circle i
said here's a video man this i just i'm
just going to tell you what i stand for
if you can meet these 15 cool if you
don't i don't have a big inner circle i
have a small one
and i don't let a lot of people in for
specific reasons so you get to choose
where you want to be if spain wants to
do it this way great more power to them
if it works out phenomenal if it doesn't
doesn't
but sometimes uh you know the reality of
it is they have tested this before and
spain
if there's anything spain needs is a
little bit of the other side
not this side yeah exactly and it's
funny because the the microcosm here is
you know
you look at this two big stories this
past week spain wanting to have people
work you know from home
short in the work week et cetera and
then you look at that goldman sachs
story in the united states where those
junior
level associates there had to like go to
the ceo and complain because they were
working up to 120.
no 100 to 110 hours a week and then the
ceo said hey
anything over 90 is a little bit over
the top man we got to give you a few
hours off
from friday night to saturday so that
just shows the difference right
dude don't go at goldman sachs
why are you working at goldman sachs to
become a senior level executive where
they're going to make 15 million don't
do it
you don't want to make 50 million don't
do it stop bitching about it nobody told
you to make 15 million
go work at b of a go work at you know a
different place don't go to goldman
sachs
i love the fact that my guide goldman
sachs picks up the call on sundays i
love it yeah that's why you do business
with them okay i love i'm a guy that
works sometimes on sundays
i'm sitting by the pool i'm looking at
the yachts and i'm making a call hey can
i talk to you
i like the fact that he'll pick up my
call and if he makes 10 million a year
does it bother me
not at all and i guarantee you that ceo
is pissed off at this because
makes him look bad number one and number
two he'd be thinking you guys spent all
this time putting this powerpoint
together
and rallying this little protest when he
should have been working i bet he was
really
secretly annoyed two things okay go
ahead i want to go through
the story usually countries
are graded on their what
gdp that's you know their level of
productivity
gross dometic product gross domestic
product um i actually interviewed
um a guy from the kingdom of bhutan
familiar with this he's uh
his title is like the secretary of
happiness
his uh you would interview somebody yeah
um
he in bhutan they they don't necessarily
use
gdp they use gdh gross domestic
happiness how
happy are the people that live in their
country
it's just a different way of doing
things but one of the things i always
say is
the big three in life is health wealth
and happiness without health you've got
nothing you need some wealth to
uh this is my philosophical views coming
again but happiness is very
good feedback you just gave right there
very good feedback
put a thumbs up if you thought that was
one of the most
magical moments adam's ever had on the
podcast double thumbs up if you want to
move to bhutan
yeah exactly gdh okay so real quick real
estate then i want to
touch on trump's uh social media stuff
and we'll wrap up the reality real
estate market article written by tom
zenner go to vtpost.com to
read other articles and by the way we
have a a
vt uh uh post insider for
dollar a month you pay for the first 90
days and it goes to 3.99 you get insider
stories that we do and a couple unique
products that we're sending your way but
the reality of real estate market there
are 1.39
licensed realtors for every house sold
in the u.s pretty crazy when you think
about this
go a little lower to show the data here
go a little lower when you look at this
data here
so uh what was it the more licensed real
estate agents than
total number of houses for sale
nationally think about that more real
estate licensed agents
than total number of houses for sale
nationally coupled with the record low
interest rates and the strongest housing
boom in 15 years and it becomes
understandable
how this could happen here's the data
all the way at the bottom if you look at
it all the way at the bottom it's an
unusual euro and real estate sector of
the economy so strange in fact that 1.5
million members
were listed in the national association
of realtors
while there were only 1 million 40 000
homes for sale across the united states
a 26
decrease from the previous year insane
it is a seller's market
sell if you can if you're thinking about
selling this your next year
sell this year okay i may be wrong this
is just an opinion i am not a real
estate expert
but i'm telling you if you're thinking
about selling in the next couple years
so this is a great point i'll back it up
with some data um 36
of the houses sold last month nationally
sold above
asking price 36 nationally
the sellers got more than they were
asking and here's the other thing every
single market has gone up
except one san francisco down people are
bailing on san francisco it's the only
major market where the cops pelosi is
probably so pissed off right now
why would you guys leave uh san
francisco and just disappoint nancy
pelosi
heartbreaking do you have thoughts on
this are you good to go you want to go
to trump
at the end of the day i think it's going
to whether just in any business
specifically real estate it's going to
be the 80 20 rule
the top 20 of the realtors are going to
do 80 of the business and the the other
are gonna fight for the scraps of the 20
that's just the same in any sales
business you know
same in uh someone else's company that
you're rocking today i assume
80 20 rule this is my philosophy right
there so there's a million
freaking realtors by the way honestly
you're on fire today no joke
water on me today okay all right yeah
trump
hints at launching his own social media
platform and the first subscriber is
adam sosnick
former president donald trump has teased
the launch of his own social media
platform but did not provide
a timeline or offer any further details
regarding the potential business venture
i'm doing things having to do with
putting our own platform
out there that you'll be hearing about
soon trump said on fox news contributor
lisa booth's debut podcast on monday
trump senior advisor jason miller also
in uh previewed plans for the new
platform over the weekend
saying that the former president would
be returning to social media in probably
the next two to three months
after being banned from twitter facebook
and other social media platforms
trump has taken to releasing statements
through his post-presidency office and
political action committee
in recent months what do you think is
going to happen with trump
launching his own social media platform
well i know you may even have a name
you're a big data guy well it's not
parlor is that that not what it is no
um well i heard that the site is gonna
flag
any statement that turns out to be true
you're so
so anything that comes out there if it's
true they're gonna flag it and be like
wow
trump told the truth that's crazy so
those statements will be flagged you are
so
um i would like to know uh uh our good
friend jason miller he says
we'll be returning to social media in
probably in the next two to three months
yep two to three months so and we also
have our other
friend alan lickman who does not think
that trump is going to be running for
president
in 2024 um he's off of social media
completely so if he has any chance
of ever winning uh presidency again he's
going to need some sort of social media
platform and this might be the key but
uh tom okay here's a guarantee this is a
prediction for me which is also a
guarantee which means it will happen
mark this one down 100
this social media platform will be made
out of solid gold okay
like everything else he does he'll have
it gold-plated the logo or something
will be gold
um here's why i don't think it's going
to work it's like the gold toilet yeah
or or the gold faucet that's maradona
the gold faucets on his boeing 757 which
is rotting at an air
yeah 100 port hanging right now okay um
it's not gonna work and i'll tell you
why because you don't rush something
like this out you're already giving
people
two to three months to prepare to not
provide a platform for him aws or
wherever he's gonna have to go
you know there's gonna be some people
that are gonna be against this it was
all the miller's comments were cliches
it's going to be the hottest ticket in
social media we're going to redefine the
game
a lot of high-powered meetings are going
on at mar-a-lago he had no details no
facts
nothing here makes me believe that he's
going to have his own platform
meanwhile there's been a covet outbreak
in mar-a-lago and the whole thing's shut
down from what i hear
wow that's not false that's uh that's
that comment is not being flagged no no
it's
not gonna be sympathetic for them in the
middle of a pandemic by the way we're
not in the middle of a pandemic we're on
the uh
the back end of the pale end of it yeah
because of it and the way krispy kremes
is doing it's going to be done in no
time so are you
excited for trump's new uh social media
i'm excited about strategies that's what
i'm excited i'm curious to know what
the next five 10 15 moves of truth
you've been very outspoken that you want
him to
curate the next set of leaders like you
want him to have sort of like a trump
university or trump
like well listen influence the next
generation yeah
the the challenge is everything's been
surrounded around
him now it's about does he develop other
leaders and teach them how to become you
know
the same way that he went from where he
was at to being a pretty
well-known figure the most well-known
figure in the world i mean everybody
around though
he had so much influence let me tell you
what happened to different businesses
okay check this out
if you haven't felt the itch to check
twitter 24 7 skim your preferred news
site or keep cable news humming in the
background
president trump left office joined the
club a few months into the new biden
administration news consumption has
significantly declined according to
washington post
cnn lost half of its primetime
viewership in the key
25 to 54 demographic and the period
president's abundance inauguration of
march 15. let me say that one more time
half half of prime time 25 to 54 that's
a 30
year span 25 to 50. so the money is
that's where the money is
online from january to february unique
visitors to new york times website
dropped 17
while washington post clocked in 26
decline washington post does this
article and they say we're down 26
okay so you know there's credibility
there trump's dramatic time in the
office was like san francisco in 1849
for media companies
that covered politics the new york times
check this out the stat
the new york times started off his
presidency with 3 million paying
subscribers by the time trump was out
how many subscribers do you think they
had
seven and a half million by the time
look at the kind of money he made new
york times cnn has its best year ever in
and drew more viewers 25 to 54 than fox
for the first time in 19 years in q4
throwing the onset of global pandemic
and door bursting subscription deals
and news companies were inundated with
traffic right following with this but
now
new york times warned last november that
subscriber games would start to slow
down
once number 45 left and it's investing
more resources into games and cooking
and other stuff
okay and and then on the bottom line it
says with dc going from house of cards
to c-span 2 the focus is shifting from
filibuster to stonks and you know he
goes in to talk about other stuff here
here's the reality of it this guy gets
eyeballs yeah no matter what anybody
says this guy gets eyeballs
and what's gonna happen with the social
media side if it's just
around his name it's gonna fail if he
goes and hires the smartest and the
brightest and overpays these guys and
brings a killer team that's done this
before and recruit some talent away
then it's got a shot but it's not going
to be if he just gets his people that
he's going to need some real solid
engineers who have done this before
with facebook with google with other
platforms like linkedin and twitter if
he draws those people in which i'm
willing to bet there's some out there
and he brings a couple hundred of them
on board and he brings the right money
behind him to do this
i think this can have likes but he's
going to have to find the hosting
services
that's going to want to back him up you
hit the nail on the head yeah and you
ask the perfect question yes
is he willing to not make this about
himself
anything he's ever done has had trump's
name on it i literally can't think of
anything that he's done without his name
trump there's university so like
for him to go out there and start
talking about anything other than trump
i think is very foreign
to his nature i don't think it's his in
his dna probably one of the best
podcasts we've done all year long fellas
great stuff this was phenomenal gank if
you're watching this prediction
gold toilet if you think you're a
subscriber and you're not just test
it out this is not valuetainment this is
pbd podcast it's two different things
that's
out there so if you haven't yet
subscribed plea please click that
button and if you enjoyed this press the
thumbs up take everybody bye bye bye bye
bye
you